aoc's abuela as far as we know is still
languishing in her unfurnished puerto
rican shack with water pouring from the
ceiling and collecting in tin buckets
strewn across the floor infamously the
congresswoman would not allow me to step
in and
rescue the poor woman from her dire
situation and i can tell you that i am
still personally haunted by that i i
still wake up at some nights in a cold
sweat shouting abuela i'm sorry i tried
abuela
aoc one can assume has slept like a baby
this entire time on the other hand
now i bring this up again because
i thought about a boiler last night
when i saw the picture circulating
online of her negligent granddaughter
cavorting with her fellow rich people at
the met gala in new york tickets for the
opulent event cost somewhere around 30
000 a piece and if you want to buy a
table inside the hall to advertise your
brand somebody keep in mind for next
year if you're thinking about this for
your business it'll run you about a
quarter of a million dollars so it is a
garish extravaganza
the ostensible purpose of which is to
raise money for the metropolitan museum
of art but in actuality the point is to
celebrate and revel in the ostentatious
wealth of the hollywood government and
media elites in attendance
now it may seem rather hypocritical for
aoc to show up at this carnival of
affluence
but don't worry the expensive designer
dress she donned for the occasion which
appears to have been inspired by a
chick-fil-a takeout bag had the words
tax the rich scrawled across it
those words change everything we're
supposed to believe normally it would be
hypocritical for a woman who constantly
rants about rich people to attend a
lavish ball with rich people so that she
could rub elbows with those same rich
people but in this case we're told her
attendance is a bold and brave and
rebellious statement all because of
those words on her dress here she is
explaining her fashion choice my god tax
the rich what a model aoc
i didn't know you model as well damn
when aurora and i were first kind of
partnered
uh we really started having a
conversation about what it means to be
working class women of color at the met
and we said you know we can't just
play along but we need to break the
fourth wall and challenge some of the
institutions and
and
you know while the met is known for its
spectacle we should have a conversation
about it
ah
yeah have a conversation now here's a
general rule
anytime somebody justifies a particular
action that they've taken by claiming
that they've done it because they want
to start a conversation it means 100 of
the time
that they're full of that's what it
means case in point later that night on
twitter aoc further defended her
attendance saying quote proud to work
with aurora james as a sustainable
focused uh black woman immigrant
designer who went from starting her
dream at a flea market in brooklyn to
winning the cfda against all odds and
then worked together to kick the doors
open at the met the time is now for
child care health care and climate
action for all tax the rich
quick quick fact check on some of this
aurora james the immigrant woman in
aoc's phrase is from ontario
now she may technically be an immigrant
but a fashion designer moving a few
hundred miles from canada to new york
isn't exactly the picture that aoc wants
us to have in mind when she uses the
phrase black immigrant woman
also when she says kick the doors open
at the met
what she means is that she took pictures
on the red carpet and then drank
cocktails with her rich friends
that's kicking the doors open
not exactly jesus overturning the tables
and driving the money changers away with
a whip if she had done that
totally different story
and when she says child care and health
care keep in mind that health care for
children as far as the congresswoman is
concerned can often include crushing
their skulls
and throwing them into a medical waste
dumpster
so other than those minor details i'd
say that her description was pretty
accurate
now with that established
i think there are a few other more
general points to be made here first
the problem let's talk about this tax
the rich slogan for a second
the problem is that the slogan is uh you
know it seems to suggest that the rich
right now are not taxed
that's why you say tax the rich because
according to you they're not
uh if they were being taxed then the
slogan wouldn't make sense it'd be
redundant
but that's not true
the rich pay taxes they pay lots of
taxes
they pay the most taxes
they pay the vast majority of taxes
tax the rich sure i agree of course we
should tax the rich
i don't think there are very many people
saying that we shouldn't tax the rich at
all
so here's the good news we do a lot
that's a fact
if you hear that the rich don't pay
taxes and you believe it
that must mean that you first of all
don't read very much
and aren't in the habit of researching
claims made by partisans before deciding
to believe them it also means presumably
that you don't make much money yourself
because if you ever had the experience
of making a small amount of money and
then managing to climb up the ladder
aways i'm not talking about all the way
up to elon musk level i just mean you
made a little bit of money and then you
had some more success and you made some
more money if you've ever done that and
achieved greater financial success
relative to where you began
you'll have noticed that as you earn
more money the government takes more
money from you
it's a pretty uh inescapable thing it's
it's pretty obvious
and at a certain point you'll observe
with alarm
they begin to take so much of your
income that you question whether the
client was worth it to begin with that's
the case right now
this may come as a shock to anybody who
previously believed that the government
rewards higher income earners by
uh politely declining to harvest their
income but that's not the case that's
not even close to the case
as it turns out the government quite
enjoys taking people's money
and the more money you have the more it
will want to stick its greasy hands into
your pockets
and when joe biden is running the
government the hand may even linger
there in your pocket for an
uncomfortable and
unnecessary length of time so
considering that the rich pay most of
the taxes
vast vast majority of the taxes are paid
by the rich where did this idea come
from that they pay no taxes
well here's a good example of how the
propaganda works this is a cbs news
headline from back in june
it says quote
is it's just the headline it says
richest 25 americans have a true tax
rate of almost nothing
wow
almost nothing
almost nothing what that doesn't sound
fair
jeff bezos doesn't he pays almost
nothing i mean what is that all about
well let's read on
it says the u.s tax system is designed
to be progressive meaning that the
wealthiest citizens pay a greater share
of their income than the less fortunate
but a new pro-public analysis of tax
data on some of the nation's richest
americans comes to the conclusion that
the richest 25 people in the u.s have a
true tax rate of almost nothing
the pro-publica report focuses on what
it calls the true tax rate which it
defines is how much in taxes were paid
by the wealthiest americans annually
versus the estimated growth in their
wealth during that time for instance
amazon ceo jeff bezos paid 1.4 billion
dollars in personal federal taxes
between 20 2006
and 2018
on 6.5 billion that he reported in
income while his wealth increased by 127
billion during that same period by
pro-publica's calculation that reflects
a true tax rate of 1.1 percent
but some
continuing but some tax experts noted
that the analysis compares what they say
are apples to oranges income versus
wealth the irs collects taxes on earned
income and income received through stock
sales dividends and other income
provided by investments it doesn't levy
taxes on unrealized gains or the paper
value of a person's assets ah okay
there it is
when they say that jeff bezos pays
almost nothing what they mean is that he
paid 1.4 billion dollars
nothing
1.4 billion is almost nothing
they justify this claim through a little
sleight of hand trick where they acquit
they equate net worth with income those
two things are not the same and it's a
damn good thing that the federal
government doesn't tax your net worth
like it taxes your income because that
would be a disaster for anyone who has
any kind of net worth at all
can you imagine that if that's what you
were doing at the at come tax time
you would assess not only your your
income for the year but your entire net
worth
and pay on that
of course many of the people in the
peanut gallery not to be confused with
the elites like aoc
who shout tax the rich don't have any
net worth have never owned anything
and so these are distinctions and points
that go over their head
now i say all this but it's not because
i care deeply about protecting jeff
bezos from higher tax rates
frankly i don't care if his taxes go up
a little bit it doesn't doesn't bother
me
my main problem with raising taxes on on
anyone is that the government already
rakes in three or four trillion dollars
a year in tax revenue and squanders
almost all of it
you know i think it's like it's it's a
three and a half trillion i think
they're up to maybe more
that they bring in tax revenue every
single year
and yet there are people saying they
need more
to do what with
what problem can the government solve
potentially that they can't already
solve with three trillion dollars
a year
there is no problem that can be solved
by giving even more money to this giant
lumbering corrupt wasteful behemoth
raise his taxes if you want whatever but
just just know that it will solve
nothing and that the policy is being
pushed based on lies and bad faith
arguments and it's being believed by
idiots who don't understand the first
thing about how the economy works and
don't even understand the distinction
between income and net worth
second point
why do you think that the rich love aoc
why do they love the tax the rich slogan
you know showing up to the met gala in
an attacks the rich dress
um that's not like if i showed up to a
planned parenthood fundraiser in in a in
a t-shirt that said imprison
abortionists
which actually sounds like a great thing
to do maybe i'll do that
but aoc you know she was embraced and
applauded
if i did that i'd be assaulted by
security and thrown out into the street
the rich are fine with the tax the rich
stuff because many of them really don't
mind paying a bit more in taxes that's
not because they're generous i mean if
they were generous they'd be forgoing
they'd forego the 200 000 designer
outfit and the expensive costume ball
and donate that extra wealth to the poor
if you wondered that i mean all these
rich people say oh yeah tax us we should
be paying more
they say while wearing an outfit that
costs more than your house
they could just give up one outfit in
their wardrobe and they could put you
know a family of five in a home and they
choose not to do that
no they they go along with the tax the
rich stuff and they call for higher
taxes themselves because for one thing
it's an easy and relatively cheap way to
virtue signal
and more importantly it gets them closer
to the levers of power
so what do what do all of the people at
the met gala have in common they're all
in the ruling class
aoc the other politicians in attendance
the hollywood degenerates who are there
all of them are in the ruling class
together they have a shared interest
they have shared goals
and that is mainly to maintain and
extend their own influence
sure they'll pay a little more in taxes
what do they care
they know those taxes are being spent by
their comrades to advance their own
ideological interests anyway
and their own financial interests
so for them
for the people at the met gala or the
people who were at the vmas the night
before
big big week for for hollywood
degenerates by the way they could bring
it break out all their uh ugly costumes
but for those people
paying taxes that's an investment for
them
they get something in return for it
i mean they get an entire system an
entire political system that works at
their best that's what they get in
return
that's why our objective shouldn't be
simply to tax the rich but rather to
dethrone the ruling class
you'll notice aoc she didn't put that on
her dress
because that's the last thing she wants
to do
third point finally
the rich also aren't too worried about
aoc's tax the rich sloganeering because
they know it isn't serious anyway
she wasn't the only one who showed up
last night with bumper sticker jargon
emblazoned on her outfit there were
plenty of you know celebrities wearing
gaudy but basically non-political
outfits like nas little little nas x was
there
he could be seen here dressed like a
c-3po's gay cousin
but there was also cara delevingne
whoever that is wearing what looks to be
a fake bulletproof vest with um peg the
patriarchy written on it
and then carolyn b maloney whoever that
is with equal rights for women printed
on a robe that looks like something that
a lesbian episcopal bishop might wear
and then megan rapino with a handbag
featuring the words in gay we trust
you know the other thing you see in all
these pictures
are the wide-eyed star struck reporters
in the background wearing face masks
and hungrily snapping pictures
now the celebrities they're not wearing
face masks
that's actually the greatest hypocrisy
on display in this entire thing
none of them are wearing face masks why
aren't they wearing face masks because
that would ruin their outfits
because it wouldn't look as nice
and it's true that you look ridiculous
in a face mask everybody does
so it's one of the many reasons why i
don't wear them
uh but all the reporters so so the uh
the you know the the servants
are all wearing masks
and the reporters who are also servants
for the for the for the ruling class
they're all in masks
aoc not wearing a mask
none of the rest of them are wearing
masks
this is really the whole thing in a
nutshell isn't it
because truly
nothing says modern leftism like a
gaggle of rich elitists at a 30 000 per
ticket gala walking around in hideous
designer dresses with shallow political
slogans and blazing across them while an
adoring press looks on drooling into
their muzzles
it's all empty
they're all just cosplaying as political
revolutionaries none of them care about
any of these issues
none of them believe in anything
but their own power and their own
influence
and last night was the perfect
illustration
of that fact
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content